I've been thinking quite a bit about the
impeachment of Donald Trump the possible
impeachment of Donald Trump and clearly
our audience has been thinking about it
as well last week during live calls we
received a number of calls about the
possible impeachment of Donald Trump and
I want to talk about the political
repercussions of impeachment not about
whether it is or isn't warranted it may
well be warranted and we'll find out
more about that
who knows almost daily we're finding out
more about that but impeachment really
could backfire and I've read many pieces
about this over the weekend which have
only heightened my concerns about the
path forward if there were to be an
impeachment of Donald Trump so let's run
run through some scenarios and remember
impeaching the president is not removing
the president impeachment is the start
of a possible removal of the President
Clinton was impeached remained in office
for his full two terms so the sort of
obvious scenario that we've been talking
about is okay well Trump gets impeached
gets removed Mike Pence becomes
President of the United States dangerous
right-wing ideologue could be likely
less scandal-ridden than Donald Trump
that means he would probably get more
done might set up Republicans to do
better than they otherwise would in 2018
or 2020 that's not a particularly good
scenario but there are other scenarios
that could actually be just as bad for
progressives first of all as Jeff Olson
pointed out in a piece in in these times
calm if Democrats can't impeach Trump
alone let me put a different way
Democrats can't impeach Trump by
themselves they need some Republicans so
first of all if you have a sort of
democratic promoted impeachment really
publicly without any Republican support
that could completely and totally
backfire you need a simple majority to
impeach in the House of Representatives
as well as a two-thirds majority in the
Senate in order to sort of convict the
president during impeachment proceedings
it could be done with all Democrats and
a few Republicans but that would be a
great situation for Republicans if
Democrats lead an impeachment
and then it fails on the conviction side
if if dot that happens Donald Trump is
completely re-energized and empowered
and I think that that's a really really
dangerous scenario now let's consider a
different scenario if Donald Trump is
convicted and impeached you have Trump a
give way to Mike Pence reliable for
religious conservatives helps the
Republican brand Republicans get the
benefits of impeachment with little risk
if just a few were to join Democrats and
that's another really risky scenario so
there's already a number of scenarios
here Pat where impeachment could
actually lead to Democrats being worse
off in both either or both 2018 and 2020
I do understand the concerns I just
think that if the allegations are true
and that the Trump campaign did collude
with Russia not only a foreign
government but an adversarial government
to help get him elected that that would
be so damning and the charges would be
tantamount to treason it would be to a
point where you kind of have to undergo
some impeachment proceedings you're
completely right and I am NOT arguing
that if the facts show that impeachment
is appropriate that impeachment should
not happen but sort of playing out how
these different scenarios might end up
impacting politics and Democrats for the
next two elections imagine another
scenario there is a democratic led
impeachment and it fails to impeach
Trump not only do you have Trump
re-energized as I mentioned you also are
probably helping Republicans in 2018 and
2020 as well and that could be really
dangerous when you think about what
would happen politically with continued
total Republican control in the House
and Senate and we can look at history
too because in 1998 of course
congressional Republicans led the charge
to impeach Bill Clinton and his approval
rating went up to 73 percent now I think
part of that has to do with the reason
that they tried to impeach Bill Clinton
over over sex scandal that's are more
important but you can see how it can
backfire so easily it could also
backfire a failed Democratic lead
impeachment could backfire because the
progressive movement right now is hugely
energized
do you realize what would happen to the
progressive movement that is so
energized right now if Democrats managed
to start impeachment proceedings with
the help of just a few Republicans and
those proceedings fail to remove Donald
Trump I don't know if you agree with me
Pat but that would hugely deflate the
momentum of the progressive movement
that is so energized right now I think
would also deflate the Trump agenda for
some time though they wouldn't be able
to really talk about health care and tax
reform if they're distracted by
impeachment proceedings and I think that
could help run out the clock to 2018 and
2020 the run out the clock idea I want
to get to in a second before I do that
though what if Republicans realize you
know what Trump is toxic we need to lead
impeachment that's better for Democrats
right because obviously Democrats would
support that impeachment if Republicans
are leading it there would be some
Republican voters who respect
Republicans saying hey you know what not
for the good of my party but for the
good of the country I as a Republican
will support the impeachment of Donald
Trump but you would have tons of
trumpets that would be mad at their
senators and members of Congress they
might not vote at all in 2018 or 2020 or
they might vote and vote Democratic to
punish those representatives that
they're angry with that's a better
scenario but it still might have the
potential to put Mike Pence in to
quietly destroy the country in far less
scandalous way or fashion than Donald
Trump so the best scenario and this sort
of gets to what pat was alluding to the
best scenario might be no impeachment
Trump stays in riddled with scandal day
after day and is able to get nothing
done with the idea that the Democrats
take over in the house and or Senate in
2018 I know it's a tall order they take
over the White House in 2020 who's
talking about the Senate voting on the
Affordable the Affordable Care Act
repealed right now nobody you know why
because it's scandal after scandal every
single day who's talking about that
aboard of Donald Trump tax plan right
now no one because it's Trump scandal
day in and day out investigation day in
and day out
we're already sort of seeing what it
could be like and that's kind of what
you're talking about Pat in terms of
running out the clock
staying in riddled with scandals for the
next three years might actually be the
best way to keep progressive engagement
up and not put Democrats at risk in the
next two elections and I think the
potential of that happening is why it's
a possibility that Republicans could
lead the effort to impeach Trump right
but if that was to happen I think
Democrats might catch on as to what
they're trying to do just trying to get
pence in there real quick to be super
clear this does not mean that the Russia
investigation shouldn't happen this
doesn't mean that I think Donald Trump
is clean this is merely a discussion of
the repercussions of how an impeachment
could have affect the path forward and I
look forward to hearing from you about
this I have a feeling that there will be
many in our audience who agree and many
in our audience who disagree with me